you're watching zweite coming up on the
show working in a war zone how virtual
reality could help train military medics
I look at the rise of nootropics the
supplements intended to push our brains
up again and we're taking charge of a
kingdom in this week's games review
welcome to swype treating seriously
wounded people must be a highly
stressful experience now imagine having
to do that in a moving helicopter well
that's what medics and the armed forces
are trained to do but convert your
reality be about to help better prepare
them for the battlefield will spin
finding out what you're looking at here
is a simulation of what it's like to
work as a medic on board a Chinook
helicopter a scene projected onto a
virtual reality headset makes the wearer
feel like they're working in a war zone
and the dummy on the floor allows them
to practice their skills on a casualty
in mid-flight as best as we can we're
using commercial off-the-shelf
components so we're using the HTC vive
headset and that's being tracked in real
time by something called the lighthouse
tracking system which is basically two
boxes with a pair of scanning lasers
that then scan the environment in which
the individual is moving and these photo
sensors on the headset will pick up the
position and orientation of the head
military medics do some of their
training in moving Chinooks but most of
their work is carried out in grounded
helicopters and this setup has its
limitations it can't replicate the
stress sights and sounds that medics
have to face on the battlefield the
experience created by the simulator
including moving images and helicopters
sound effects as the potential to make
training feel much more like reality we
want to be able to give people at least
partly the impression of actually being
within that medical environment you're
up in the air you've got the vibrations
you've got the sound effects you've got
the unusual light distortions from the
rotors and and prepare people for all
these additional sort of visual and
audio inputs they're just not used to
one of the benefits of this setup is its
flexibility
virtual cabin can be easily inflated and
deflated so it can be packed up and
moved between bases but despite the
clear benefits of using virtual reality
will we ever get to the stage where a
simulation can fully prepare someone for
real warfare I think it can come very
close clearly nothing actually prepares
you for the reality of undertaking
missions in a conflict zone and actually
doing missions in a conflict zone where
we can take people as close as is
reasonable so when people face it for
real they have a proper frame of
reference to draw on this project isn't
being used by the Ministry of Defense
yet and further work will be needed
before it's introduced but the
technology it uses certainly has the
potential to revolutionize the way the
military trains its medics will sergeant
Sky News stay with us still to come
inspired by Silicon Valley biohackers we
meet one business owner taking cognitive
enhancers to stay sharp at work that's
coming right up after a roundup of this
week's tech news this is the moment a
group of scientists step back into the
real world after living in a dome in
Hawaii without fresh air for a year the
experiment was meant to simulate what it
would be like to live on Mars with the
team only allowed to go outside if they
were wearing spacesuits Apple was
ordered to pay up to 11 billion pounds
in back taxes to island this week the
European Commission ruled that a special
scheme to route profits through the
country was illegal both Apple and the
Irish government deny any wrongdoing
Amazon's launched its dash buttons in
the UK their physical buttons which sit
around your home that you press when you
want to reorder everyday items for
delivery like coffee washing powder pet
food and shaving gel and Mark Zuckerberg
had a business meeting with the Pope
this week well kind of the Facebook
founder and his wife Priscilla Chan
dropped into Vatican City for
discussions on how to use communications
tech to tackle poverty the new tropics
trend is growing if you've never heard
of that term before it basically refers
to a whole load of supplements and drugs
that are meant to enhance cognitive
function they're said to be all the rage
among some
Silicon Valley tech entrepreneurs who
want to be able to think faster remember
for longer and be more productive so
I've been investigating the trend and
the potential risks one of his goons a
busy working mom has ways to stay on top
of things Sadie has perhaps an
unexpected one she's big on nootropics
that's the buzzword for a new generation
of substances taken to make users think
faster remember for longer and
concentrate harder this is my supplement
cupboard that i've been using i actually
started off with just the one drawer but
slowly what's been happening is i've
been getting rid of all my spices and
i'm actually taking over nootropics
could technically be anything from
caffeine to unlicensed medicines or
psychedelics Sadie those sticks to legal
and mainly natural compounds and usually
what I do in the mornings to be honest
i'll just make a decision how I'm
feeling and what it is that I actually
want to do for the deer for her the
supplements have become a useful tool it
really need to be on the ball all the
time I'm a mom I'm busy old I mean I've
got about three different businesses you
know if I'm in a meeting I need to be
able to remember stuff and recall
information nootropics also known as
smart drugs appear to have had some
beginnings in Silicon Valley where high
performing tech entrepreneurs try to get
an edge over the competition now the
trend extends to well anyone it's hard
to know officially just how many people
are taking nootropics but go online and
there are forums and podcasts devoted to
discussing them there's one user here
asking which nootropic will be most
beneficial to take while learning a new
language someone else over here is
asking which nootropic would be best to
take instead of a cup of coffee in the
morning and it seems fans don't just
want to push their brains up a gear they
want mental preservation too they've
seen their parents who've you know maybe
had Alzheimer's had seen al dementia
kind of seen what the you know the last
decades of life can be like as far as a
cognitive downslope and so they're
they're very um you know anxious to make
sure like you know I saw what happened
to my parents I want to make sure that
doesn't happen to me
some scientists studying the effects of
cognitive enhancing drugs say there are
groups of society who could really
benefit from them air traffic
controllers doctors working at night
people in the military that way they
could keep themselves or other people
safe however we need to know that these
drugs are safe the healthy people to use
in the long term at the moment many
nootropics fans by over the internet and
with some of the drugs that's illegal
also customers can rarely know what
they're really getting it's a very
dangerous position to take if you think
you're going to go online and get a
genuine medicine you may well not be it
could be something completely different
it could have a different active
ingredient you could have no active
ingredient it could have twice the
potency that you actually thought might
be in there the idea of improved brain
performance though seems to have many
willing to take that risk now if you
have a dreamt of being a king with the
power to boss your subjects around this
week's games review it's gonna be a good
one for you here's Holly
reigns is a game in which you take
control of the kingdom and you've got to
have the longest reign how many years
you can get now the rains all add up so
you start at the beginning and you
progress through history so you remember
what you did in a previous game now you
make decisions by swiping left and right
you know to say yes or no interaction
with people in front of you it's
brilliantly funny very weird wonderfully
written it looks great you'll give the
way you've got to do it is there are
four stats which represent the church
your popularity the wealth of the
country and the army now you've got to
balance these stats you don't want them
to fall to zero but you don't want them
to get to the top / eyes at the end of
your reign if you're looking for a game
to kind of play for two hours really get
into you swipe and left and right then
this is game for you mr. robot is a
really interesting experience for your
phone now it's inspired by the show of
course at the same name however you
don't need to be a huge fan of the show
to enjoy it even if you haven't watched
it there's still a lot to be found in
the game so the game takes their place
as an app interface the idea is that
you've picked up a phone and the owner
of the original phone is messaging you
and contacting you so it acts like it's
your real phone it does really
interesting things that send you
notifications it sends you messages it
plays on the themes found in the TV show
the idea that were constantly connected
to our phones wanting to be into this
communicating technology if you're
looking for a unique experience then
this game will really fulfill your needs
legend of the skyfish is a puzzle
platformer that is both beautiful and
just oozes quality and gameplay it is
inspired by villagers elder series but
instead of feeling like a ripoff it
feels like a really loving homage it is
gorgeous the art style is absolutely
beautiful and it is also enhanced by
really brilliant sound designer music
just adds to the experience now I was
surprised because I played on iPod and
sometimes controls on a touch screen can
be a bit fiddly a bit cumbersome
especially if there's more than two
things going on however the controls of
Legend of the sky
she felt really slick they felt very in
control very tactile of really impressed
by what they've managed to do that's it
for this week but don't forget you can
watch any of our episodes on our youtube
playlist just type in sky new swype and
take a look at Sky News on mobile tablet
catch-up sky cute and snapchat for all
the latest tech stories throughout the
week and we'll see you again next time
bye-bye